I'm a believer that when you build a
business based around you and what it is
that you believe in that there are no
real competitors out there it's a 100%
original business Chris thank you so
much for coming on the show thank you
for having me it's good to be here this
is going to be fun what is a personal
brand a personal brand is what people
say about you when you're not around
it's what you're known for all
entrepreneurs are salespeople right
we're selling our ideas our Solutions
our thoughts our opinions personal
brands are salespeople personified and
everything we do is a sale situation and
the one thing that I teach my clients
and my students is that just be yourself
if you're yourself you're not going to
come across a sleazy or salesy you're
going to come across someone who's
helpful any parting advice for me you
know I'm 28 years old doing this
personal brand thing I would
say oh by the way in case you have not
yet heard my book is about to come out
it's called Feelgood productivity how to
do more what matters to you and it's a
book that I've been working on for the
last 3 years now it's being published at
the end end of December 2023 but
pre-orders are actually available and I
know people don't like pre-ordering the
book but if you do pre-order the book
and you email me your receipt you will
get completely free access to a live
exclusive event that I'm hosting in the
first weekend of January of 2024 and
this is a live online Workshop all about
annual planning goal setting and
reflection and so I'm going to be
facilitating a group with hopefully
hundreds of people from all around the
world and we're going to be going
through how to figure out what to do
with our life and how to turn that into
goals for the year and how to build
systems and how to be consistent with
stuff and how to make sure that we are
enjoying the journey along the way that
is purely exclusively available for
people who pre-order the book as a thank
you for our little community so if you
want to check it out you can check out
the book you can maybe consider
pre-ordering it the link will be down in
the video description Chris thank you so
much for coming on the show thank you
for having me it's good to be here this
is going to be fun um I'm going to start
things off with a bit of an unusual
question um have you come across that um
there was this article a while ago 36
questions to fall in love no it's like
the the theory was that these
psychologists got a bunch of people
together and realized that if you get
two people on a date and you ask them
you just you ask each other these 36
questions um and then you stare into
each other's eyes for a few minutes
you're more likely to fall in love um
are you going to start asking me these
questions now now I know why I'm sat
directly opposite you for this interview
right one of those questions is um tell
me your life story in under four minutes
God so I'd love to start with that for
the people that might not know who you
are what is your life story well I was
born at a very young age I can guarantee
you that um and from there
uh not the best student studied hard not
the smartest guy at school um certainly
learned a lot more from reading books um
as an adult than I ever did at school um
didn't do
University uh got married very very
young had two amazing children very very
young got divorced not so young um then
went to uh the Philippines uh in the
early 2000s spent 18 years there set up
uh I think I'm skipping over stuff now
but I want to make sure I get this in in
four minutes um worked for a big
infomercial business in the United
States um always been sales and
marketing my entire career always sales
and marketing uh the infomercial stuff
was fine so yes but wait there's more
and all that kind of stuff um Kevin
Harrington uh one of the original sharks
was also a scen on TV guy used to hang
out with him quite a bit back in the day
um and then set up our call center
facility in the Philippines my wife and
I my second wife and uh from there
everything else kind of just snowbo um
the personal brand the speaking the
books the students the clients and now
I'm here at some weird studio in London
talking to some guy who's uh young
enough to be my
son so there you go that's about it
that's a good place that's a good place
to kick things off um let's start with
with the sales and marketing how did you
get into sales and marketing what's what
was going on there so was part-time job
uh my first job for um a secondhand car
newspaper and um I just had to sell
classified space simple as that um 17
years old on the phone and to call
people out of the blue from the Yellow
Page literally the Yellow Pages that was
my my qualified leads yeah um that they
were my uh were my leads and I would
start at the beginning of the book and
then work my way through to the end of
the book and so you're phoning people up
so what are you saying on the phone have
you got a car boat motorcycle that you
want to sell uh we can you know help you
do that for x amount of money uh in next
week's copy of of the newspaper and how
many how many people would just like put
the phone down like what what sort of
responses did you get to a cold well at
first obviously I didn't know what the
bloody hell I was doing right so it was
kind of like you know hello my name's
Chris you know would you like to place
an advert to help your Vesper or
whatever it
was or your your your 150 Suzuki or
whatever it was you know and um it was
hard I'd be lying if I said it was I
took to it like a duck to water I didn't
at all um it was it was very very hard
and I I think it must have taken me the
best part of probably three weeks of
like pretty hardcore calling to make my
first sale I made about seven or eight
pound commission I think um which to was
back then was not a lot of money it's
not a lot of money now it's a lot less
money now but I was definitely bitten
with the bug and here in the yes after I
made the offer was kind of the the
beginning of um a life in sales
marketing really you know there was
something about being able to get a yes
at the end of me saying I can help you
do this thing I'm the solution to your
problem would would you be happy enough
to pay me something for that pain point
to go away you've been trying to sell
your you know rusted out Ford ca for the
last two months you've said I can help
you do it uh you know and then you know
after a while you listen to everybody
else you know guys that were in the
office that have been doing a lot longer
than me you listen to them then you know
the old adage was the sales stroke much
like when you stroke a a cat if you
stroke a cat it starts purring right and
so our job as as sales people and you're
sales person by the way CU you're an
entrepreneur all entrepreneurs are
salese right we're selling our ideas our
Solutions our thoughts our opinions uh
personal brands are salespeople
personified I mean everything we do is a
sales situation every time we record a
YouTube video or a podcast episode or
write an email to our list we're
ultimately selling as to why should you
carry on listening to me how am I going
to help you in the future etc etc etc
right and so just the ability to be able
to help somebody out with something as
simple as selling an old beaten up car
or a motorcycle was kind of just called
to me and we had this thing there was a
bell okay there was a little bell on the
wall in the office and whenever you made
a sale you could go and ring the bell
and I just loved ringing that Bell man I
just loved ringing it and so that was it
it was kind of and once you rang the
bell once you wanted to R it you at that
point you wanted to ring it every day so
that meant you would make more s you
would you know make more offers pitch
more learn how to handle the rebuttal
better etc etc etc and that's just uh
that was how it all kicked off why do
people have such an aversion to the word
sales because it it I think a lot of
people think
that being sold to is like being forced
into something to a certain degree like
oh this guy's a
salesperson he's going to try and sell
something and I think that that's why
there's that initial
um you know that initial friction
between what people think and you know
particularly that whole kind of used car
salesman snake oil sales and that sort
of type of thing um and the one thing
that I I teach my clients and my
students in regards to building a
personal brand and the business based
around expertise is that you know you
just just be yourself just be yourself
if you're yourself you're not going to
come across a sley or salesy you're
going to come across as someone who's
helpful who's got value in them that's
there to serve and I always believe that
you sell first and you sell sorry you
serve first and you sell later right and
so the sales process if you look at it
and you break it down step by step it's
you know uh
prospecting then you qualify that
Prospect if they qualify you move move
on to you know talking about your your
product your service your
experience uh features benefits you
might come over a rebuttal or an
objection rather to which you will have
a rebuttal then you get back to your
your pitch right your offer then you
might have another objection to get over
rebuttal and eventually at the very very
end of the sales process is the close
right and this is what always has
surprised me is you you you go to Amazon
you type in how to close a sale or books
on closing sales and you see all these
things 25 ways to close a sale easier or
you know 50 sales closes that really
work you know and all this kind of stuff
I've never thought about in fact
actually I can honestly say to you I've
never been worried about closing a sale
because I'm just a big believer that the
sale or rather the the Clos part of the
sales process is just a natural
conclusion to that
process if you've done everything right
up to that point the sale actually
should happen all by
itself I'm a big believer of that and
that's why I don't do the hard cell
that's why you know this is the problem
that you've got this is how I can
potentially help you and when you're
ready to be helped you know where I am
I'm not going anywhere you know so I can
honestly say that I I you know through
all of our students all of our clients I
don't have to push anybody in fact
actually people are just
waiting to jump on board because of the
fact that I just come from that place of
value and serving and I think that is
missing a lot in today's world and that
is probably one of the main reasons as
well why people look at sales
professionals um with a negative
attachment I've well one thing I've
heard from a few people is oh I would I
would start a business but I don't want
to be a Salesman what's what's going on
there impossible
impossible if you're going to start a
business you are going to be a
salesperson otherwise your business
isn't going to be around for very long
everybody selling something product
service
experience you know it's just one of
those things you you go to
Disney you go to a Disney park and you
get off a ride nine times out of 10 when
you get off that ride and you want to go
out into the main street of the park
again you're got to walk through a
souvenir or gift shop of some variety
they're selling you it's very subtle
it's passive but they're selling you and
the vast majority and to use just to
stick with Disney by the way I'm a big
Disney fan I'm a dad I got four kids two
are adults now but it's tough to be a
parent and not you know love Disney
right and I love Disney I think they're
a great company but boy do they know how
to sell Disney are one of the best
companies on the planet to sell and
there's just no way that you can start
you can start
something not worry about making money
and not make money but you can't call
that a business because a business makes
money right you can call it a hobby I've
got enough Hobbies I prune bonsai trees
that's a great hobby I love my bonsai I
play with Lego sets with my kids that's
a hobby I collect Pokemon cards that's a
hobby too right but none of those things
make me money well actually probably
sold a few Pokémon cards before but like
other than that my business is my
business is where I make my real money
and so I I don't think it's possible to
start a business and not be involved in
sales particularly initially anyway you
know what did you mean when you said
that creating content is selling well
because when you publish that piece of
content you're selling somebody on
either a your opinion or B the ability
of you being able to help them in some
capacity with the content that you've
created and published right so I mean if
we use you as an example and what you do
on your YouTube channels you are helping
people to live a more productive a more
fulfilling more joy filled life that's
your jam that's a good phrase yes we
should steal that yeah let's write that
down um I I know where to send the the
invoice for that abely um but no I mean
you know and and and that that's your
jam that's what you're all about and you
create content every single week that
you put out to an audience that's
growing um over you know every single
month your audience gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger why because
you're selling them on the idea on how
you can either educate entertain or
Inspire them and every single piece of
content that we create the one of those
three things right also every single
time you hit publish on a YouTube video
or publish on a podcast or publish on a
blog post every single time you do that
that you're creating a business asset
that will live for 24/7 365 days a year
to help you grow your business it's an
asset is what that is and it's a
money-making asset as well because it
only takes one person finding a video
that you published two years ago to fall
in love with what you're all about they
then go and buy your book they then go
and buy one of your courses and before
you know what's happening as in when you
potentially decide to do it you've
opened up your Mastermind it's 50 Grand
a year to be a part of it and they've
jumped on board
all because of one YouTube video that
they found randomly because that's a
piece of content and you sold them you
sold them on why Ali is so great and why
they need to follow you yeah I always
think of think think of videos as as as
assets as well it's like you know we've
we've made a few videos where like one
of our videos it's got like 10 million
views even just on AdSense income alone
that video has made over £100,000 it's
just utterly ridiculous because to make
£100,000 from property you you would
have to either flip a property buy at
auction do a ton of work on it and
then flip it for 100k or you're you've
got like 30 years worth of yield to get
to 100K in property as an and yet this
video that took half an hour of planning
an hour of filming and someone else a
few hours of editing has turned into
into this ridiculously valuable asset
yeah and over time over the last six
years we've made 580 or videos just on
the main YouTube channel all of which
are directly passive income generating
assets but they're also ating you know
tomorrow someone could watch a video I
made six years ago because they're
applying to med school and be like oh I
want to check out check out more of this
guy the algorithm is helping as well
because often people don't even have to
make an active choice to watch more of
my stuff but if they've watched it and
the algorithm knows that they watched
enough of it to register as an
interested viewer it will surface more
of it to them and it's just this magical
like virtuous cycle that just yeah yeah
yeah and now you know when when we look
at like monetization of a personal brand
you know you've got things like courses
and and coaching and Consulting and
speaking and writing books and
masterminds and in your case because
you're creating content on a regular
basis that's going out to a mass
audience you've got things like
sponsorship Google ads or rather uh what
do you call it YouTube ads AdSense you
know all that kind of stuff like those
things like the sponsors that are
jumping on board now are going
after putting something in front of your
audience as it is right now
but what you the sponsors and even your
audience members have to understand and
really appreciate is that those sponsors
as great as they're going to be and as
helpful as they're going to be to your
current audience are only here because
you've busted your
ass doing what you do every single day
to create all those mini assets that are
ultimately going to mean that they want
to part with money to get in front of
your audience so that's something that
you need to celebrate as a content
creator and as a personal brand as well
well this is not in any way shape or
form
and like this is not out of the blue
like this isn't something that's just
come out of nowhere this has been slowly
but surely having a compound effect on
your following and on your influence as
a personal brand for a long time um and
the companies that end up and sponsor
this show or any other show for that
matter they um they're getting the
benefit of all that hard work you know
what is a personal brand
a personal brand is what people say
about you when you're not around that's
what your personal brand is it's what
you're known for so when you're not at
that conference or that dinner party or
that coffee meeting um and your name
pops up in the conversation what are
people saying about you that's your
personal brand it's what you're known
for ultimately I'm very much on your
page here in terms of sort of I've drunk
I've been drinking this this kind of
Kool-Aid and living in this world for
for a for quite a long time yep but
often I'll find uh when I throw out the
word personal brand people will kind of
like the word sales people have a bit of
a a cringe response to that what's
what's going on there I I think it's
because I think personal branding as a
whole I mean look it's not a New Concept
personal brands have been around for
decades and decades right um but I think
it's still a little unknown it's it's a
little unknown it's a little unsure in
terms of what it is and how it works and
I feel I also feel
like
because a lot of people don't know
people who have personal brand
businesses um it's kind of like a weird
sort of ice it's almost like an iceberg
right like see an iceberg floating
around somewhere in the Arctic you can
see what's above the water but you can't
see what's underneath it so you see the
influence that the personal brand is
having you see potentially maybe the
money that that personal brand
entrepreneur is making but you don't see
what's underneath right and iceberg what
are they like 10 times bigger underneath
than they are on top of the water or
whatever so that's that's a whole bunch
more there that's that's opinions that's
relationships that's um you know the
things that make them tick the things
that they hate uh the things they want
to stay away from their experiences the
people that they want to do more
business with all that stuff is all
underneath and that's unknown that's
unknown whereas the stuff on top is
known very clearly because it's it's
forward facing it's the front cover of a
book or it's who the person is on stage
or on a camera you know on on YouTube or
on Twitter or insta or whatever it is
and so I think a lot of people see
personal brand entrepreneurs as somewhat
vain because they they're putting
themselves out into the world and you
see a lot of these influences so you
know hi everyone welcome back to my
channel you know today I'm that's me
be yeah but then it's usually followed
up you know some of the some of the
things I've seen you know you know today
I'm going to be cleaning my kitchen why
don't you follow along hey you know what
if you want to watch somebody clean
clean the kitchen fair play go ahead and
watch them you know they built that
personal brand there you know somebody
who focuses on looking after a busy home
or something like that and there are
people out there that are going to want
to watch that sort of type of content
because they want to speed up the house
clean every week or they want to become
a more productive mom or dad or parent
or whatever and so I think that a lot of
people look at the personal brand on
entrepreneur and the element of personal
branding with a bit of a frown almost
because they don't know how it works
they don't know what's involved in
building a business based around a
personal brand as well what's the
difference between a personal brand and
a I guess professional reputation or is
it is it the same thing just kind of in
different kind of words I think it is
yeah it is it's just a different way of
you know it's a different way of being
able to say this is what I do yeah
ultimately yeah cuz I guess when I talk
to my mom about this she wouldn't
understand the word personal brand but
if I if I said hey you know that famous
surgeon that you know he's got a
professional reputation right she's like
yeah of course yeah that's a personal
brand yeah haha gotcha you know that
kind of thing Y and I think maybe in
some in some in Industries some
instances you would use one and you
would never use another like for example
a doctor yeah a doctor wouldn't say I've
got a personal brand I wouldn't say a
doctor unless it's like Dr mic or some
other American right Dr Phil or
something like that yeah yeah yeah um
and I mean you know Dr Phil is the
perfect example of a personal brand as
well got his own show he's got his books
he's got his you know he does what he
does you know Oprah one of the biggest
personal Brands the planet's ever seen
and probably likely will ever see she
got an incredible story behind her she's
spoken and interviewed some of the most
influential important highly respected
individuals that the world has ever seen
and therefore you've got that
Association of what you know there like
everybody knows who Opa Winfrey is
everyone you stop anybody in the street
show a photo of her you're don't even to
say your name oh that's Oprah that's a
personal brand it's what you're known
for should everyone try and cultivate a
personal brand
no no not really I I think that you know
if
you're if you know that you never want
to build a business and you're quite
happy building a quote unquote
traditional career working for other
companies and things like that that's
not a personal brand that is a
reputation that's a career reputation so
you know if you want to be an architect
you've got to go to college you do you
know x amount of year is working in AR
architectural offices you're building
models you're working on CAD you're out
on the street sketching you're doing all
these things eventually you get a job I
think uh starting salary for an
architect and the reason why I'm using
this as a example right now is because
my son is uh picking options for his GCC
right now and he wants to be an
architect and so you know we went
through all the different options for
him Art and Design and graphics and all
this sort of stuff um and I actually did
some research on it uh I think 30 to
45,000 there starting salary for an
architect thereabouts uh and then you
know you can get up to 60 within a few
years and you're building a career like
that that's a reputational type of
career that's not a personal brand um
and if that's the route that you're
going to go no need for you to build a
brand it's it's fine you don't need to
build a personal brand but if likewise
if you were to then fast forward 25
years and you've been involved in
architecture for 25 years and you've got
an incredible reputation you've got this
body of work that you can pull on to
show your expertise and your
experience but you don't want to carry
on working for other companies anymore
and instead you turn around and say hey
you know what I want to teach younger
Architects how to build a great career
now you can potentially start thinking
about that as a personal brand element
because you've moved on you're no longer
having to work within the industry
you're serving the industry by helping
the next generation of Architects come
up through the ranks so that's you know
one way of looking at it but no not
everybody should come up with one I
don't think it's a prerequisite that we
have to you know we have to have a
personal brand in order to get a a job
or whatever I would say and I say this
to all my kids um maybe not so much
Cassandra who's five but all the others
I've I've said you
know hey that conversation will happen
man sometime it'll happen but like I
I've said it to all of them like you're
using social media I get it I use it too
but everything you put on social can
come back to bite you in the ass at some
point right um just be careful what you
do because that that is your online
reputation and if if you are going for a
job with a good firm that is going to be
looking at who they're hiring properly
and it's not just down to the
recruitment agency that they've used or
the IQ test that you've gone through
whatever it is they they will look at
that sort of type of stuff and that's
the kind of stuff that can come come
back to haunt you I mean if you can
haunt stand up comedians and actors and
actresses and things like that it can
definitely haunt people that are looking
for jobs as well so let's say I
am studying architecture at University
and I'm thinking you know I I want to
actually be an architect I don't want to
be one of those you know architect
dropouts that start a YouTube channel
for now I want to study architecture I
want to build my professional reputation
I want to network with the right people
maybe I'm active on LinkedIn maybe I'm
going to these conferences and just
trying to build up a decent body of work
but I'm also thinking in the back of my
mind you know I can see myself based on
the sort of person I am you know
back when I was in school I was selling
candy bars whatever um I'm thinking
maybe I want to start my own firm one
day and preferably sooner rather than
later once I've got a bit of experience
under my belt and hm maybe this personal
brand stuff could be interesting in that
position let's say someone is a
professional in a traditional career and
they like the idea of a personal brand
firstly what's what's the benefit of
them trying to build a personal brand
within a professional industry and then
how would they go about it well I mean
obviously it will give you options
further down the line that's you know
that's a big you know a big benefit for
sure um in terms of going ahead and
actually starting it and doing it I
would be in this day and age I'd be
really really upfront with my boss and
I'd say hey I'm thinking of starting a
YouTube channel where uh I'm going to
show people how to draw or how to use
CAD or how to make 3D models or whatever
it is that people do in architecture you
know offices My Father Was An Architect
so kind of grown up around that a little
bit um and uh I just thought before I
start doing it I'm not going to mention
my company that I'm working for or
anything like that opinions are my own
and all that sort of stuff but would you
have a problem with it or not because
you're better off being upfront with
that and getting the green light from
your boss then you would do putting an
entire year into it the boss is not
liking it and then getting into trouble
that wouldn't be a good situation to be
in at all but it would certainly give
you opportunities further down the line
it creates options which is never a bad
thing at all you know but Ali honestly
you know we're sitting here talking
about this if you'd have told me you
know 17 18 years ago when I opened the
doors to my first
business that I would be writing a
bestselling book on building a personal
brown business that I would be making
money to speak in front of complete
strangers on stages around the world um
and have you know tens of thousands of
people tuning into my show every week
like I would not have seen this coming
at all
this has not been planned or at least
initially it wasn't right I'd like to
think that I've been a little bit more
strategic in the last seven or eight
years but at least at first like I
didn't even realize I had a personal
brand until I got my first book deal and
then I realized it was one one
particular conversation that I had with
the Publishers uh who said my first book
was called virtual freedom and they said
that they liked the concept of the book
and the proposal for the book because it
felt like it was the Outsourcing life
section of the 4our work week that never
got printed kind of thing was like the
next step kind of thing um and that's
great and that's going to put you on
another pedestal Chris and I was like
well okay that's great and everything
but I'm not really I don't really I just
want to help people like I'm not I'm not
writing this book to go on to you know
to move up a pedestal or two like this
is just what I've gone through in the
last four five six years I burned out in
20 2009 and then had to come back from
from that and part of that process was
hiring a whole bunch of people to
replace myself some virtual some not but
then you know I started blogging and
podcasting and all that sort of stuff in
2010 about vas and virtual teams and all
of a sudden BOS I'm getting a publishing
deal because I'm the VA
guy right so okay great I've always
wanted to become a public a published
author that's a goal that you know let's
take that off uh you know the the the
list and we move on from that but then
what happened was after the book came
out people started to say to me how did
you do that how did you get the book
deal and I started reverse engineering
it back and I said I got the book deal
because I was publishing content three
times a week on my blog and I was
podcasting every week and you know I was
doing YouTube videos every now and then
I was on Twitter you know back when you
know Twitter was like really cool when
it first started right and all this sort
of stuff and you reverse engineer back
you realize actually I'm building that
personal brand up over a period of time
and it just ended up culminating with a
book deal so then that's where upo was
born that was where if I can do it for
nothing there's no reason why I can't
help other people do it as well and that
that was where upo was born is there is
is there a way to build a personal brand
without I guess quote creating content
or is that really the main lever I mean
I think there probably is uh I I don't
think you need to you know one of the
one of the easiest ways for us to spread
our message our opinions our
ideas and our thoughts today is doing
exactly what we're doing right now it's
getting in front of other PE other
people's audiences right um and know
your people will tune in and I'm a
little Marite right I people either like
me or they don't like me there's not a
lot of messy Middle with me and I'm
actually fine with that as well I think
pretty much every content creator should
be like like that you know you either
love it or hate it like M might have it
they've got it down right in terms of
marketing like they lean into that love
it or hate it thing so well and it works
brilliantly and I think the same could
be said for personal Brands as well but
this was not something that I really
thought was going to happen but now I've
just rolled into it and I think that the
majority of people who jump on board
with the idea of building a personal
brand um and they understand the power
of it and there is a certain amount of
responsibility in involved as well
obviously as you get more and more known
and respected uh your opinions and what
you say online really matter
particularly but no I I don't think you
need to create content yourself but I
think in today's world you definitely
need to
be you need to be in front of other
people via their other people's content
maybe yeah because I guess back in the
day it was like you know you would
publish a book which would be gept
behind a publisher you might be on a TV
show yep like Tony Robbins back in the
day was on TV shows and selling CDs and
stuff to get in front of people y um or
you might be speaking on
stage and hope that the people speak on
stage enough times in front of enough
people for your personal name reputation
to get known yep whereas now because of
the internet like creating stuff for
putting in the internet or appearing on
other people's shows is just or Tweeting
or LinkedIn or writing or photos on
Instagram or sketch notes on Pinterest
or answering on quora or making YouTube
videos there's all these different ways
of expression but fundamentally it
sounds like we're saying building a
personal brand is about getting your
thoughts your opinions your values in
front of other people and you can do
that through whatever medium you want
but fundamentally just it needs to be
public you can't really build a private
personal brand unless you're one of
those Anonymous personal Brands which is
another side of things yeah it's it's
yeah and it's not something I really
know a whole lot about to be honest I
mean you know one thing I also get I get
quite a lot of people say you know what
kind of domain name do I buy do I buy my
name.com or do I buy a business name.com
and the answer actually is pretty clean
cut if you're going to build a business
based around you your expertise your
style what you stand for you get your
own domain name but if you're going to
build something bigger than you a
movement of some variety or a brand of
some variety then you know that can't be
under your name because at some point
you might want to exit in that scenario
and it's very hard toit it with a
personal brand domain than it would be
for uh you know for something that's not
a personal brand name this episode is
sponsored by kajabi and they've actually
got something really valuable for all of
our Deep dive listeners now if you
haven't heard of kajabi it's basically a
platform that helps creators diversify
their revenue with courses and
membership sites and communities and
podcasts and coaching tools so it's one
of the best places for creators and
entrepreneurs to build a sustainable
business we started using kajabi earlier
this year and as soon as we started
using it we were like oh my God why
haven't we been using this product for
the last 3 years it's got everything
you'd possibly need for running an
online course or hosting an online
community or building an online coaching
business and it essentially makes it
really easy to run your entire online
business from payments to marketing
tools to analytics kajabi has everything
that we creators need all in one place
and actually you don't necessarily need
a huge audience to generate a
sustainable income a Creator on kajabi
can for example make $100,000 by
converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using jajab to host
all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to our $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple $100 a year and actually in their
lifetime kajabi have paid out over $6
billion to creators that's billion with
be and over a thousand creators have
become millionaires through products on
the platform now back in May 2023 I did
a keynote at a kajabi in real life
kajabi Heroes Event in Austin Texas and
in that keynote I talked about the exact
steps that I used to grow my business
from zero to over2 and a half million
per year from course Revenue alone now
people paid for the pretty expensive
tickets to watch this keynote at the
kajabi hero live event but as an
exclusive deal for deep dive listeners
kajabi have very kindly offered to
provide the recording of that keynote
completely for free to anyone who
listens to to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode this episode is very kindly
brought to you by none other than hu now
I've been a pain customer of hu since
2017 I first discovered it in my fifth
year of medical school and if you
haven't heard of it it's basically a
meal in a bottle and in that meal you
get a balance to mixture of
carbohydrates and fats and proteins and
fiber and it also contains 26 different
vitamins and minerals and each meal has
around 400 calories and 22 g of protein
so it's pretty reasonable in terms of
protein count and because I tend to be
pretty busy and there's always stuff
going on I tend not to really have time
to get a healthy breakfast or a healthy
lunch and so I'll often use hu ready to
drink as a replacement for my breakfast
or my lunch they've got eight different
flavors that are available my two
favorites are banana and salted caramel
so if you find those you should check
them out and even though hu as a company
started off online direct a consumer
recently they've propagated amongst all
of like the grocery stores in the UK at
least and so I've been seeing it out and
about everywhere which is pretty cool
and very excitingly we also have an
episode with Julian Hearn who is the
founder of hu back on this podcast from
season 1 and so that episode was a real
masterclass entrepreneurship and it was
really cool seeing kind of hearing the
story of exactly how heel came together
so head over to heal.com for/ Deep dive
and thank you so much he for sponsoring
this episode when I when I speak to my
mom about about this stuff she doesn't
really she she feels a lot of fear in
the sense
of YouTube channel like what what's
going to happen in a few years time she
sees kind of the rise and fall of these
makeup lifestyle type YouTubers on like
the guardian and she's like I'm really
worried this is going to happen to my
son cuz what's in one year is not in the
next year um which is strikes me and and
and I agree with her on this like there
are so few YouTubers who are big today
who were also Big 10 years ago with the
exception of a few like Tech YouTubers
or in certain in certain niches how do
you think about kind of the longevity of
a personal brand and a personal brand
business is it a thing like can
you can you be like right I'm going to
I'm going to focus on my personal brand
and kind of do that forever or does it
have like a sell by
date I don't I don't think a per like I
don't think a personal brand really has
a sell by date personal
brand business might have a sell by date
whereas you end up wanting to
stop um but that doesn't mean that the
work that you've created through that
career won't stick around for ever as
well I mean one of my
biggest kind of mentors I'd never met
was a guy called Zig Ziggler who's an
American author and speaker um and you
know like I said never met Zig I've met
two or three people that have worked
with him uh I've become uh I've had the
opportunity to rather to uh interview
his son who now runs Ziggler Enterprises
and all the rest of it but you look at
zigg he's you know he passed away way
years ago yet his personal brand is
still quite synonymous with success and
sales particularly um and you know ever
since discovering his stuff when I was
15 years old was halfway through my
gcses I discovered an audio tape um at
the local library called see you at the
top and I'll never forget the S line it
was it's a checkup from the neck up was
very very very American uh and I'm just
this guy in Wimbledon this 15-year-old
kid whose idea of uh you know working
through life is you know playing
basketball skateboarding and doing his
best to impress girls um and failing at
pretty much all of them to be honest
with you
um but there was something about zig's
words and I I got his cassette um and
took it home and listened to it and
there was something about his his way of
you know talking and explaining and
motivating
that you it's very hard not to
appreciate that kind of the life that
that kind of person's living and that's
the reason why to this day now his books
still sell people are still talking
about him and you know his quotes are
some of the most shared quotes on social
media you know like you can have
everything in life that you want if you
help other people get what they want you
know this this sort of stuff doesn't go
away it's been around for decades that's
the kind of personal brand that you know
he's he's no longer with us but his work
is still with us and that kind of brand
I don't think do you know that doesn't
have a shelf life you know that will
that will be forever but there'll be
other people you know that will come and
go a little bit and it kind of it is
what it is you know but I don't I don't
think it's I don't think it's as clean
cut as just saying this is this is the
way a personal brand business is built
and it's only good until this point I
don't think as clean cut as that and I
also think it also comes down to how
much impact you have and how many people
actually help out as well so how would
you go about building a personal brand
business like what is a personal brand
business mean what does it do how what
what are the steps to Mak first thing is
to figure out exactly what it is you
want to be known for Now understand
you're not marrying that right like it's
just what you're going to be known for
now Y for the foreseeable future so once
you discovered exactly what it is that
you want to be known for then it's your
job then to figure out who it is that
you're going to help so you know you can
call it a customer Avatar if you want or
whatever um but this is what I do this
is how I can help people this is the
type of people that I'm going to help
but my my kind of big thing here is to
try and Niche that down as much as
possible so you can hit the ground
running as quickly as possible after
after you get going right so you know I
could say well I'm a health coach and I
help people get healthy that's okay but
it's a little vanilla there a whole
bunch of health coaches out there right
but if you say I'm a health coach that
works with men now I've cut out the
female population for my marketing for
my language that means that obviously I
can only work with men right women are
not going to be attracted to what I can
do for them but by that being said you
know the man is a very big niche as well
so I'm a health coach who works with men
in their 40s now we're niching down even
further I'm a health coach who works
with men in their 40s who are recovering
from
surgery now we've got a niche
now we can start creating content now we
can you know create an optin and put it
on our website or our landing page and
start building an email list now we can
think about what types of courses or
one-on-one Consulting work we can do or
maybe there's a on to many program I can
put together a cohort based course or
something like that so I think figuring
out what it is that you want to be known
for figuring out who it is you're going
to help and then figuring out how you're
going to help them it's kind of the
three big starting
points what if someone's thinking I want
to build a personal brand but I don't
really know what my Niche is going to be
how how would we go about I mean you can
you can you know if we use because
obviously your audience knows you as a
YouTuber right so if we use YouTube as a
niche I mean really it comes down to
vlogging like you know the Vlog idea of
follow follow my life this is what I do
you become the content right it's not
what you can do to help somebody
initially they're following along
because they like you they like your
fashion they like your lifestyle they
kind of almost want to be like you to a
certain degree right so you know that's
one way been able to do that but you
know also I don't know as much about
YouTube as you do but I do know that I
think it's probably a lot harder to
build a channel based around following
you around in your day-to-day life than
it is a subject of some variety what
I'll be right in saying that 100% yeah
yeah yeah yeah Vlogs are basically
impossible to grow a vlog Channel these
days unless you have unless you're in
the
0.001% of people who who happen to make
it in that um yeah or or you've built
your personal brand already in another
capacity and people care about following
your own Will Smith starts vlogging and
everybody you know jumps on you know
yeah so I guess I mean so I'm I'm very
very familiar with this sort of stuff on
on YouTube where because you know
through a course everyone's always like
was my Niche um and usually I say that
first start of just making videos about
anything
because you need to actually just make
your first 10 or videos and then and
then worry about actually getting good
at making videos still about anything
because we need to train the chops of
actually knowing how to make a video and
once you know how to make a video and
it's actually not cringe and you don't
look at it and feel embarrassed at that
point we can start thinking right do I
want to treat this like a hobby or a
business if you're treating like a hobby
great Happy Days carry on carry on do
what you want but if you're going to
treat it like a business now at that
point let's think about the niche let's
think about the market let's think about
who the competitor analysis let's think
about how you're going to stand out out
in that particular Niche um but I think
a lot of times people overthink the
niche question when they haven't even
got started but I guess YouTube is a
specific skill because there's a lot of
like how how to make videos that goes
into it do you think there's like what
what would be like the niche Discovery
process for like some of the people that
you work with if they were like right
Chris I really want to build a personal
brand so I can monetize it later but but
I don't want to show my face on a
YouTube video what are some alternative
rootes to building that personal brand
well I mean the podcast is always a
great route um I you know the funny
thing about podcasting is i' I've been
podcasting since
2010 so what's that 12 years now 13
years all in um and a lot of honestly
podcasting is still in its infancy I
think in terms of the the the general
population the way that we consume that
particular type of content um but I mean
like podcasting is a great way you never
have to show your face you have to wor
about your makeup um you know Amy
Porterfield very good friend of mine she
uh I remember when she started her show
and she said to me um oh podcast so much
easier than YouTube I don't have to
worry about my hair don't have to do my
makeup I can record it in my pajamas you
know that sort of type of thing so I
think podcasting is a great way to do it
I don't think blogging is dead I think
blogging still has a really really solid
uh foundation for a lot of people and
the building of their personal brand
Google is going to love you because
they've got all that written content to
crawl um and I think that you know
anybody that's really serious about
building a personal brand website
specifically should definitely be
creating written content as well um but
really you know I think the consistency
is the big thing more than anything else
people
generally give up too quickly and you
probably see this on YouTube as well
with some of your students or the people
that come into your your world you know
they they publish their first 10 15 20
videos you know their mom the neighbor
and their dog subscribes and they're
kind of oh what's the point no one's
watching kind of thing and they give up
you know Malcolm Gladwell the Tipping
Point job you know you're right there
man just keep going it'll become so much
easier and I think a lot of people quit
on building personal Brands and building
uh what could ultimately end up being a
really profitable impactful you know
personal brand or expert based business
because they're not seeing the traction
that they want straight away um and I
feel like that's the big thing or the
other thing is this people pivot too
quickly so they you know they'll put out
x amount of content over x amount of
period of time they don't see it working
and so they say well I'm not really
interested in productivity anymore I'm
going to start doing videos on how to
play the guitar all those other videos
all that other content is pretty useless
at that point now uh so changing your
mind not being consistent not being
clear on who it is that you're helping
or you want to you know entertain or
whatever it is all those things come
into play so on on YouTube I say that if
you make a video every week for 2 years
then I guarantee it'll change your life
I can't put put any numbers in it I
can't tell you how much money you'll be
making 100% guarantee it will change
your life at the very least in terms of
the skills you learn the confidence you
gain the person you become the friends
you make along the way what would you
say is an appropriate length of time to
give the personal brand a shot before
calling it quit well I mean so we have a
program called the upo incubator and
within that program at the very core of
it we have what we call our sixf figure
road map and it will basically take you
from zero to six figures in an annual
you know Bas on an annual basis in terms
of Revenue and I often say that you know
ultimately I believe you can get there
with inside of two years I believe you
can but that's without changing your
mind every five minutes that's without
trying to do all the things straight
away overnight that's about getting the
foundations in place it's about knowing
exactly who it is that you're working
with knowing exactly how you can help
them making sure that you're showing up
consistently with what it is that you're
doing and how you're doing it and
understanding that you can't put all
your eggs in one basket in terms of
monetization as well so at first we have
four we have a four tier monetization
kind of framework the first one is based
very much around time for money so you
give an hour of your time for x amount
of money that's what we call our oneone
power hour all right Next Level Up from
that is a what we call a pilot product
your pilot product is ultimately your
flag ship course right it's usually
pretty lowlevel stuff not super intense
but a course of some variety that will
get people lots of quick wins and bring
in some money so you start off with
something that's not really that
scalable at all and then introduce
something that's more passive and more
scalable next level up from that is what
we call our champion product Champion
product is taking people from uh where
they are to where they want to be within
a certain P certain amount of time for a
certain amount of money invested so you
know I we we use the health coach again
for an example I want to lose1 in the
next 60 days for example well you know
within that 60 days I'm going to give
you eight videos one video a week
there's going to be a shopping list for
you to download whatever it is right
exercise regime whatever um and putting
all that together that's your Champion
product and then at the very top is what
we call our Clockwork product the
Clockwork product is what we would you
know class as sort of a an old school
mrr a monthly recurring Revenue High
ticket offer where every single month
like clockwork somebody's investing
money in you for you to help them get
whatever it is that they want um and
really that's that's it that's your six
figure personal brand business right
there now it's not as simple as just
creating all that stuff and getting it
out there but you know holding events
running webinars building an email list
and building a team all those other
things there I believe two years it's
more more than doable to build a sixf
fig personal brand business if you're
focused and you're not changing your
mind every five minutes and do you think
anyone anyone can build a six-figure
personal brand I think they wanted to I
think anybody who has the inclination to
do it
A and B the ability to ultimately help
people through what they know can
absolutely do it yeah H yeah I guess
it's that second one that at least a lot
of people I speak to view like
like for example if you asked if you
gave people the option would you like to
have a YouTube channel within two years
that was making 100K everyone would be
like yeah yeah I'd love that would you
like to have a personal brand business
where within two years you could be
making 100K hell yes how how can you
help people again uh I don't know you
know it's that how how do I help people
Point like how do you how do you begin
to figure that out is that how does how
do people develop that ability well I
think you know going back to our our
example of kind of like the architect
who's working 25 years build up a great
career and then decides to go the
personal brand route they've earned
their stripes already it's going to be a
lot easier for them to do it a lot
easier but then the flip side of that
coin is somebody like yourself who's
kind of initially got known for doing
something who then started helping
people to do something and then that's
kind of developed into a whole new thing
it's not by accident it's by hard work
but clearly you can see that you can
speed up the process you don't need to
do 25 years I think what you do need to
do though is be really clear on who it
is you're helping or who you're serving
for sure and how you can potentially
show up for them you know for you it was
about productivity and getting more done
and you know that sort of type of thing
um you know for for somebody like Tim
Ferris it was all about working less and
making more you know and I think you
know there's a lot of people online that
that have great personal Brands who
potent potentially probably weren't that
clear on what they were doing and how
they were doing it when they first got
going but over a period of time certain
things have happened conversations have
taken place opportunities have Reed
their head and therefore obviously
they've been given those opportunities
and they can move forward with them yeah
there's a question I like uh that we
have as part of um our kind of finding
your Niche session for our YouTuber
Academy which
is if you had with with zero preparation
if you were asked to do a 20-minute talk
teaching someone something who would
someone be and what would that something
be and generally people are like oh I
would I would help someone 5 years
younger than me figure out what to do
with their life because all of my mates
younger siblings keep on asking me this
and they think I have have have a good
answer or I don't know I've been I've
been playing tennis my whole life and
people just love my backhand and so I
could I would teach a a amateur tennis
player how to improve their backhand
slice things like that that then start
to come out where you start thinking
okay could I potentially make a viable
YouTube channel out of this and do I see
enough I guess growth potential and
monetization potential within that
particular Niche for it to be a path
worth pursuing based on what else I
could be doing with my time but I think
the problem is when like you know a
17-year-old who spends their time in
school during the day and watching
Netflix in the evenings is trying to
then build a YouTube channel like where
they don't have any expertise they don't
they they haven't as you said earned
their stripes doing something because I
think you have to kind of do something
first and then you can teach people how
to do the thing or you've just got to be
ridiculously entertaining yeah yeah
that's the entertainment if you look at
YouTube like all the stuff that I see my
children watch on YouTube yeah for me
it's just a bunch of old TSH yeah you
know like all this Roblox stuff and
video games and and you know and I like
Pokemon cards but I can't sit there
watching people open Pokemon cards for
an hour you know what I mean like but
the kids love that stuff right my son
literally doesn't watch anything else
yeah other than YouTubers and some of
them are better than others but they're
all pretty entertaining to him
and so therefore that's his Jam that's
what he's into so you can either help
people and serve them that way or you
can just be really entertaining and fun
to watch and that's absolutely fine you
know I mean you look at somebody like
aie
man he's not really helping anybody do
anything other than have a bloody good
laugh right so that's what he's doing
he's just entertaining people that's it
he get to sell his merch and make his
money and do what he does yeah I I guess
in the world of YouTube that I'm in I
almost don't even I I almost don't even
think about the entertainers which which
actually makes up like 99.9% of YouTube
there such a small percentage of YouTube
that's actually educational yes but it's
like I've in my in my mind before I
started making YouTube videos in order
to be a YouTuber you had to be
entertaining and I immediately
discounted myself cuz I was a nerd and I
was never entertaining anyone um but
then as soon as I shifted from oh I can
teach on YouTube suddenly it unlocked
all of this this whole other side of
YouTube yep um but it's I think it's
easy for me to forget that actually the
vast majority of people do not watch
educational content on YouTube YouTube
is fundamentally you know the biggest
thing in YouTube is music the second
biggest is gaming even Tech is like a
tiny tiny Niche compared to like gaming
and music which is all entertainment
right and Vlogs lifestyle it's kind of
crazy like there's one channel that I
watch uh with my daughter sometimes
called art for kids club okay it's a big
Channel yeah and what they do is the dad
who's obviously a professional
illustrator sits next to one of his kids
so you know he's got like three kids I
think at varying degrees of development
right and so so you know if he's sitting
there with his little girl be like so
today we're going to draw a hardboard
egg sitting in an egg cup so he'll draw
and his little girl will follow next to
him and you can see both you know both
both pieces of paper and stuff you know
if it's his kid is going you know today
we're going to be doing the his older
kid you know the Hong Hong Kong
landscape or whatever right and I I
watch those videos with her and we
actually draw together that to me is
both educational
and entertaining you can see from a
parental perspective the joy of being
able to be there with one of your
children and having fun and he has a
giggle with his kids and stuff like that
when they're doing it um and you know I
remember there was one episode where
they were drawing a snake and his
daughter decided to draw the snake
perfectly straight and he goes I've
never seen a snake with with a perfectly
straight tail like that you know and I
thought that was just the way he said it
I just thought it was hilarious it was
very entertaining to me but for the for
the it was like oh yeah that's true my
snake should be crooked or you know
those kind of channels exist and I think
they're an anomaly they're not you're
either one or the other I think pretty
much across the board but it's
interesting how you say you don't think
about when you think about YouTube you
think about what you do right can I turn
the tables very quickly so like why do
you think that is why because obviously
you consume content on YouTube as well
I'm assuming you're not just creating
it's the stuff that you consume on
YouTube only things like what you are
producing or are you watching things
like gaming and music and entertainment
as well I watch almost zero
entertainment content on YouTube my
entire YouTube feed is podcasts and
educational channels and stuff that's
kind of similar to my stuff right
similarly when someone you know if I
were to ask someone how do you make a
book here the New York Times booking
bestseller list in my mind I'm of of
course I'm thinking non-fiction
self-help I'm not in fact thinking of
all the cookbooks or all of the
different of fiction and and and it's
only it's only when I'm speaking to
someone who's a fiction author which is
unusual like I was chatting to my editor
the other day who has colleagues who do
fiction he mentioned oh yeah and
obviously there's like these 20
different categories in the fiction list
I was like oh yeah fiction books exist
and I you know I read I read a lot of
fantasy fiction but I've just never once
thought of a fiction book hitting the
New York Times list because to me that's
almost synonymous with our kind of
industry it's and it's out of your world
EX whereas it like the man Booker prize
of the year I'm like okay that's fiction
award
things like that I it's like the world
I'm in and similarly most of the people
that we teach on our are educational
YouTubers whereas erak who's like big
entertainment YouTuber also has a course
where everyone in his course wants to be
an entertainment YouTuber so they're
doing his method of growth on YouTube is
collabs and big pranks and big
challenges my method is find find an N
you can become an expert in analyze the
market yeah provide value it's just a
different sort of way kind of almost
like you're sticking with what you know
from a consumption standpoint as well as
a cre ation standpoint as well and I
could probably definitely do with uh
sort of widening my content consumption
diet as it were yeah because watching
entertainment videos is also you know
it's it's educational in a way um but
yeah I don't I don't spend a lot of time
actually watching YouTube videos other
than oh no I do actually I watch
educational World of Warcraft videos
because I play World of Warcraft and I
watch videos about like some guy with
2,000 subscribers who's like a uh
preservation evoker healer and teaching
us how to do Mythic Plus Dungeons and
I'm like oh yeah I love I love the way
he's done his rotation and so I watch
those while brushing my teeth in the
toilet with my airpods right so okay so
let's let's have some fun with that so
like your everything you just said in
the last 30 seconds went right over my
head I know of World of Warcraft
obviously but I'm not interested at all
any any that um but you are and
therefore you even though the guy's only
got a couple of thousand Subs you're
still consuming that content start
following him when he had like 300 subs
and I was just like this guy's sick now
so do you see the power of Niche with
that yeah the power of Niche is very
prominent right there whereas you don't
watch a whole of other stff but because
you're very specifically involved in
that Ty of content you'll dive in
whether whether he has 2 million subs or
2,000 or even 200 Subs if there's
something there that you don't know that
he does he's serving you yeah exactly
that's the power of a personal Brands
and there are and and I think crucially
for him there are so few people hyper
targeting that specific Niche again just
to use the World of Warcraft example
there there are people about how to
improve your World of Warcraft skills
fine but then there are people within
that how do you how to improve your
World of Warcraft skills as a warlock
and then within that it's like how to
improve your warlock skills as a
specific kind of warlock using a
specific kind of specialization and it's
like oh great that's the one for me Y
and if the person targeting that Niche
is in a market of zero then everyone
looking for that content is going to be
following them there you go whereas
they're trying to compete with how to be
a better gamer you're competing with 5
zillion other people and it's never
going to happen so what you've just done
is reverse engineered what we were
talking about earlier health coach yeah
health coach with men health coach with
men in the 40s and so on and so on so on
but that's the way different brains work
you see I think what are the things
people struggle with when it comes to
like health coach under 40s who've just
had surgery health Co health coach men
40y olds who've had
surgery they might worry that uh oh this
this Niche is not big enough uh will I
be confined to only speaking to men in
their 40s what if one what if one of
them's 48 and two years later they they
become 50 will they suddenly stop
watching my stuff what if I what if I'm
no longer interested in serving that
Niche yeah how do you how do you think
about that well I think okay so first of
all the 4est thing obviously is just an
approximation you can say
midlife and that can be another 20 years
30 years if you wanted to right um but I
think you know the the concept of the
pivot comes around a lot and fact I saw
this a lot with the pandemic a lot of
people were doing one thing and then
they kind of used the pandemic as an
excuse almost to sort of go and pivot
and do something else and a lot of
people when the pandemic first hit
everybody that I was coming into contact
with they were they were pivoting like
mad oh we got a pivot we got to Pivot
the world's changed we got to Pivot why
have you got to Pivot man it's been fine
like okay we're going to get through
this thing like you don't have to change
your entire message your entire business
model the everything that you do just
because this situation has happened now
maybe one or two in these shees you
might would have been beneficial to do
it if you were running live events for
example pivot to online events sure but
I I just think that a lot of people also
they get married with what they get
married too for too long much like with
a marriage if you're not happy in that
marriage if that marriage isn't bringing
you Joy anymore it might be a good idea
for you to potentially end that marriage
and move on and try and find a new
partner right same thing can happen with
your business if you're working with
something if you're working in a
specific Niche and you're serving a
specific person and to use Marie condos
you know it's not sparking joy for you
anymore and you're feeling a little you
know if it's really affecting you by all
means look at a pivot but don't do it
just for the sake of doing it because
it's cool or everyone else seems to be
doing it there's got to be a very clear
reason behind you know pivoting like
that what is a
UR a youpreneur is somebody
who genuinely builds a business based
around their expertise okay so it is the
content creator it is the professional
speaker or the author or the educator
it's somebody who who you know when I
look at our our programs at yo.com I
look at all the different levels that
people come into some people are right
at the beginning of their Journeys uh
some people are more you know more
advanced more further along in that
journey and I always say that no matter
what where you're at in your development
as a upur you're exactly where you need
to be right now we can help you get to
the next step and the next and the next
uh but but a uper at the very core is
somebody who who who is at least at the
very least deems themselves who has a
certain amount of expertise and what
they do and how they do it so it is for
example one of our members um is been in
the financial game for a long time and
uh he left his role as an independent
financial adviser uh about seven or
eight years ago and went out and wanted
to become a keynote speaker and an
author didn't want to do the independent
thing anymore so he figures out right
well I've got all this in my I've got
this all this is in the tank got all
this expertise I've earned my stripes um
and this is how I these are the three
things I've come across over and over
and over again in my career I'm going to
focus on these three things it's three
books three Keynotes three coaching
programs and I'm going to turn myself
into that business that's a youer nice
yeah what are some other examples
outside of the sort of YouTube World um
people that you've you've got in your
look at what we got we have an
innovation coach who works with uh
companies who focuses on explicitly
helping them innovate with inside of the
workplace um and that particular
individual is part of my Round Table
Mastermind he's just signed a
multi-million dollar deal with a very
very large company so you know that's
another perfect example of taking my
expertise taking what I'm known for and
plugging it into a number of different
situations where I know I can serve and
help um what else do we have we have a
another member inside of our uh Round
Table who is um runs a membership site
for Kung Fu teaches people how to oh do
kung fu online all online sure could you
get that on YouTube yeah sure there's
loads of kung fu demos on YouTube but
that's where Community comes into play
so now you're paying your 50 Quid a
month or whatever it is to be part of
that Community you can do your live
classes they've got the archive that you
can dive into you can learn how to do
this do that etc etc but now you're also
part of the cool kids club now you're
part of the community
and actually I
feel as we go on more and more Community
I think is probably going to become the
biggest marketing asset for businesses
period but for personal brand businesses
it's going to be like pouring gasoline
all over an open fire when you've got a
community of individuals that are on
board with what it is that you say and
how you say and what you stand for and
how you have been helping them that's
the biggest billboard that's the biggest
set of Facebook ads that you can run
because after our own opinions we're
more likely to believe the opinions of
the people that we know love and
Trust So when you say oh you know if you
want to learn how to build a business
based around your expertise you need to
go and check out Chris Ducker because
he's been doing it for years
and if I don't know Chris but you do and
you're suggesting I go check his workout
and I know you and I trust you I'm more
likely to do that rather than to look
somewhere else
this season is Once Again being
sponsored very kindly by trading 212 now
people ask me all the time for
investment advice uh because they see
that I've made money and I've made
videos talking about where I'm investing
that money the thing that Warren Buffett
and basically everyone who's sensible in
the space recommends which is to invest
in Broad stock market index funds which
you can do completely for free using
trading 212 trading 212 is a fantastic
app that lets you invest in stocks and
shares and funds in a commission-free
fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfol Olio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest feature so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge font Trader
who's gone onto the platform and has
created a pie of Investments having done
a bunch of research and stuff and that
pie might be like I don't know 20% Apple
20% Tesla 10% this 10% that but it
generally way more complicated than that
and you can see the performance of that
particular pie of stocks and shares and
funds and then if you want to copy that
pie into your own account you can just
copy and paste it directly in and then
you can invest any amount of money and
it will automatically split it according
to the allocation in the P so if you
wanted to just play around with £100 and
you were like okay that Pi looks good it
will split out that1 based on the
allocations of the pi which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of100 so it's literally free money
so you might as well so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode so you've got this book rise of
the uprer um the definitive Guide to
Becoming the guy leader in your industry
and building a future proof business
what's the what's the road map here what
what what are the kind of steps that
someone needs to needs to take I mean
we've gone through some of them um the
entire book is focused around what we
call a three-step framework of build
market and monetize so you're building
your roots you're marketing what it is
that you want to be known for how you
can help and then you're monetizing the
expertise as well so I mean at the very
core that framework is is the book it's
part one part two part three um but I
mean you know a lot of what we've talked
about here today has been quite
foundational uh the book certainly
paints a very clear picture in terms of
what you should be doing and when as
well there's certain things you
shouldn't be doing too early on because
you're just not ready for it you know
you wouldn't install the plumbing and
the electrics in the house if you didn't
have the foundations and the walls put
up right and so you know I often say
when you're looking at you know building
a team for example you wouldn't hire a
plumber to do your Plastering you
wouldn't hire a roofing expert to do you
know your electrics for example the
chances are your house going to fall
down right same sort of type of thing
when you're building that that future
proof business of a business based
around your expertise and that is that
you know bit by bit Brick by Brick you
can build it up over a period of time
where you are genuinely setting yourself
up to become future proof now when I say
future proof I want to just dive on that
very quickly if I can I'm a believer
that when you build a business based
around you and what it is that you
believe in that there are no real
competitors out there sure if I call
myself a business coach for example
there might be other business coaches
out there that call themselves business
coaches as well but none of the other
business coaches are going to coach
business owners the way I do that makes
me unique right so when you build the
business of you which we talk about in
the book there are no real competitors
out there it's a 100% original business
likewise because people fall in love
with you with your audience as an
example they love you and what you stand
for and how you help them if at some
point in the future you want to Pivot a
little bit and go in a slightly
different
direction you will be future proof
because those hardcore subscribers and
followers will go with you they'll pivot
with you because it's not so much about
the content that Ali puts out it's
actually about ali himself and that's
the definition of a personal brand
business owner being future
proof nice um the reason I discovered
your your work in the first place was
your first book virtual Freedom mhm um
and we were talking before recording
that you did a talk uh 45 ways to use a
virtual assistant in 45 minutes y um
most people please don't ask me to do
that again now it was absolutely
knackering it really was it's the worst
speech idea ever because you got 45
minutes on stage you're going to do 45
things a literally didn't breathe right
yeah yeah
um I've been thinking for a while that I
want to make a course or a video or
something called The lifechanging Magic
of a part-time personal assistant um
which is basically the VA stuff uh what
I I imagine most people listening to
this do not in fact have a personal
assistant or a virtual assistant who
should consider hiring a virtual
assistant and like I guess what is a
virtual assistant who should considering
hiring them and I guess once we've done
that we we'll talk about how to go about
it I think vas virtual assistance in
general it's a general term nowadays
right um when you think about
Outsourcing and you think about vas in
general I think a lot of people just
have this idea of just a like a virtual
a remote version of a personal assistant
so it's somebody who does your calendar
maybe checks your email for you books
your hotels and your travel maybe P pays
your bills that kind of stuff and some
vas can do that for you there's no doubt
about it but in the world of building a
virtual team itself you have a lot of
different positions a lot of different
roles I mean you know we were talking
about how you've got all these different
people working for you in different
roles the number one rule actually of
hiring people virtually and hiring
people period whether they're on the
other side of the world or sitting in
the room next to you is to hire for the
role and not for the task so the analogy
of you know if I want to build a house
I'm going to get an architect on board
first then I'm going to find my general
contractor then I'm going to find my
brick liting guys my Plastering guys and
my plumber and my electrician and all
that sort of stuff right and then the
house is built does it stop there does
the is the team done no I might need an
interior designer cuz the sofa I'm going
to pick is horrible right so now I've
got an interior designer on board as
well and so on and so on and so on hire
for the role not for the task when it
comes to vas a general VA which is a
term I believe I coined many many years
ago or a gva I talk about it in Virtual
Freedom um is someone that is a general
helper of online business owners so it's
people it's somebody who can do things
like upload your YouTube videos for them
not edit but upload those YouTube videos
uh reply to comments manage your social
media manage your email you know uh sign
up and set up you know the OD landing
pages that sort of type of stuff right
if you want to build a website you need
to hire a web designer and a web
developer because it's very very rare to
find a developer who can also design and
vice versa right if you want to create
videos you better have a video editor uh
and maybe it might be a video editor who
can also do animation as well like you
know there's all these different things
come into play um I often joke around a
little bit and say like you know if
you're not a graphic designer you have
no right being in Photoshop trying to
design your company logo like just hire
someone to do that so that's task based
Outsourcing right there I've got a logo
that needs to be designed I'm going to
go ahead and actually Outsource that and
get that logo designed I pay them I pay
the designer to do the logo they go
ahead and give me my Logo game over
thank you for playing everybody's happy
right the project-based Outsourcing is
you know I need to redesign my website
so you're going to need a graphic
designer you're going to need a
developer you might need a copywriter as
well all these people come on board on a
project basis once the website is live
you pay everybody for what they did you
get your website game over thank you for
playing right but then you've got the
role based and that's where the magic
happens that's where the trophies come
into play because when you hire for the
role you're building a team so what
might start with the gva will then
become a gva with a Content writer a gva
with a Content writer and an SEO person
a gva Content writer SEO graphic
designer graphic designer Facebook ad
manager Facebook ad manager you know uh
you funnel Builder you know all these
different roles come into play and
that's when I start getting exciting
about stuff
because what happens eventually there's
there's a line that you've got to draw
in the sand between building the team
and then actually owning the business
because what happens is as and when you
get all these different people in unless
you get somebody to manage all of those
people you go from being a business
owner doing everything to hiring people
to help you do all that stuff so you
don't have to do it all to then hiring
more people to build a team to then
actually not being a business owner
anymore now you're just a manager of
people and so generally the route that
you want to go is that one of those
first two or three hires needs to become
the person who then manages the entire
team and then you can go back to doing
what you do sitting in your Z your zone
of Genius etc etc your business would
not be able to do what it does if you
were still editing all your videos if
you were still updating all your social
if you were still writing all your
emails couldn't do it there's only one
alley there's only so many hours in the
day yeah I think that that's kind of
accidentally the exact format that we
followed actually it probably was
accidental is probably because the stuff
in your book like to say because you
read the book just thinking of that
where like Angus who was initially a
remote uh blog post writer for like one
project a week ended up becoming my kind
of right-hand man be full-time the
general manager of the business that's
the way it works you know you you find
people that can help you with one
particular thing and then you realize
much like the iceberg that there's a lot
more going on there and you can go ahead
and actually get more out of them you
know and initially if you really got a
business hat on your head initially what
you're thinking is is I can get more
bang for my buck here right I can get
them to write my emails and edit my
videos and do but it doesn't work like
that not not if you want to do it at a
certain level where you're going to get
some real serious success out of it and
that's why it's important to hire for
the role and not the task nice changing
gears a little bit um one thing I often
hear from entrepreneu type people uh is
that they kind of regret not
prioritizing Health in relationships
when they were younger mhm is that true
for you or do you think you had a good
balance between those like work Health
relationships those three I guess
pillars of a good life think's a little
tough
because I've always been a pretty
healthy guy for the most part um I'm I'm
also quite outspoken where I say I don't
really like exercise um it's not because
I'm lazy because I'm certainly not a
lazy person I just it doesn't like when
I was playing ball when I was you know a
teenager into my early 20s I play
basketball three four times a week
that's a workout right you don't play
ball to get fit you got to be fit to
play ball right and so I used to be
ridiculously fit ridiculously strong and
as I've
aged um maybe that's not as good as I
would want it to be but also I am I
think I'm probably more in tune with
things like sleep for example for sure I
definitely prioritize that way more than
I used to before um I had back Sur many
many years ago uh how many years ago now
10 years had an L5 S1 Fusion which
wasn't pretty um and I never want to go
through anything like that ever again so
I think as I've gotten older I've
definitely prioritized Health a lot more
you don't eat as much junk you maybe
spend a little bit more time I mean
certainly I spend more time reading and
in solitudes today than I have done ever
before um walking I've fallen ahead of
it he was in love with nature and the
outdoors didn't get that so much living
over in the Philippines cuz it's so hot
over there that you can't walk for 50
minutes without sweating through your
shirt right but when I came back to
England four and a half years or so ago
I realized oh my God I'm in the
countryside here like I can go walking
and like see rabbits and stuff like this
is cool you know what I mean so
definitely as I've got older that's
become more of a priority in terms of
relationships it's a little hard to tell
because I was married and divorced by my
mid
20s and I was still very much in a j o
scenario back then we had kids very
young and therefore I had to work hard
you know at one point I had three jobs
right for as long as I've been an
entrepreneur I've been with my wife with
my current wife love of my life right
and
so and we we have grown all of our
businesses our group of businesses we've
grown them together from the ground up
we've never had any partners yeah we've
never taken any loans every time we've
expanded we've done so from profits etc
etc so for me and my wife s the the
business and the relationship is kind of
syor oneon-one
um and she's pretty good at keeping me
in
check she's pretty good at keeping me in
check you know when she sees me kind of
maybe doing a few too many hours or
which I'm getting better at nowadays but
certainly you know if if if I'm getting
stressed out or or you know I'm working
too many hours or whatever they she'll
call it she'll call it step away go take
a walk go wire a tree or something you
know bot TI has been a big thing for me
man oh yeah yeah I don't know I mean I'm
not saying it's it's going to be good
for everybody but I got into it right at
the very beginning of the lockdown right
and um you know I knew I wasn't going to
be traveling anywhere or anything like
that what started with picking up a
couple of little trees at the Garden
Center and or trees shrubs and then
butchering them and bending them into
weird shapes and stuff it it very
seriously expanded quite extensively and
I have a fullblown bons like Garden on
my property now oh nice I it landscaped
and everything so nice I I'll have to
come and visit sometime you Do's wide
open well you were you were just around
the corner at one point I know it's
really annoying I'm in London now yeah
and then we got to know each other and
now you moved you know it's reallyy yeah
um what's it like running a business
with your wife amazing really most
people say oh you know whatever you do
don't go into business with your family
and all that I love it okay so I'm
blessed yeah okay I'm blessed because my
eldest son is a videographer runs his
own Media company he's got his own thing
when I need a videographer I call on my
son I'm also blessed because my daughter
Chloe who's behind that camera the
close-up camera right here she's behind
there she graduated uh business Commons
with marketing and so she works with the
company so I get to spend every sing
single day with my daughter which is
just amazing right and then my wife who
runs the operational on the finance side
of the business I don't want to look at
spreadsheets Ally spreadsheets give me
nose beds I've got no intention of
looking at spreadsheet so my wife is
great with that stuff I am a lucky guy I
get to spend every single day at work a
working with people that I love being
with in terms of uh my clients and my
students but then likewise I get to
spend
all this time with you know two of the
three ladies in my life and it's
fantastic I love it I love it I know
it's not for everyone but I I could not
see myself doing it at this point in my
career without them both of them you
know
yeah what does success mean to
you uh not working Fridays which today
is an anomaly today is a Friday we're
recording on a Friday um I I haven't had
anything on my schedule other than
working or rather other than traveling
or speaking for gigs uh I haven't worked
a Friday for about eight years now so
not having having that no work Friday is
is massively important to me um but
overall you know success for me is being
able to do what I want when I want to do
it really you know and also like being
in control of my schedule like that's a
big one I often say like if it doesn't
get scheduled it doesn't get done and I
got that from one of my uh mentors my
Hyatt and he said that one day and I was
just like oh so good why didn't I think
of that right um and I feel like being
able to be a you know to be in a
position where if you don't want to work
one afternoon and you've got nothing on
your schedule and you and you can leave
and go and watch a film with your wife
or you know go and you know go and have
a walk or whatever like that for me is
that's massive success right there
that's huge success do I want to make
money yep because it's a business it's
not a hobby I've got the Hobbies Hobbies
cost you money yeah they don't make you
money right yeah that's a good a good
distinction yeah so you know do I do I
want to make money yes do I like still
closing sales of certain you know of
certain varieties yes I do um do I still
get a kick every now and then when uh
you know a PayPal notification might
come through and I've just made a call
sale for
$350 yeah all right that email funnel is
working you know that kind of thing
that's success I like doing that that's
fun but ultimately at this point months
away from turning 50 I just want to be
able to honestly I want to work less and
have more impact and work with fewer
people and just dive deeper into their
worlds and how I can help them love it
if you had 100 million in the bank what
would change about your your calendar
and how you spend your time
what would change about how I spend my
time God that's a good one see it's a
tough one because you got kids they've
got to go to school um you could
homeschool I get that but we don't um
that was a big realization in the
pandemic by the way lockdowns we're not
teachers I didn't sign up for this right
didn't sign up for algebra at all as a
teacher
um I mean
certainly certain way more charitable
work I mean we we donate quietly to V
various charitable causes you know every
single year we built schools and
libraries and all that kind of stuff
overseas and whatnot but definitely more
charity stuff but honestly I mean if I'm
to be a little selfish by it I think I
would I would genuinely do a heck of
heck of a lot more traveling with my
wife you know me and my wife when we
travel it's like business rarely will
come up in discussion um even when we
might travel and might kind of like put
something on the end of a speaking gig
or something um we love being in hotels
we love traveling we love seeing
different things and we often joke that
by the time all the kids have grown up
and they're off and they're doing uni
and they're out you know doing their own
things and like we want to be the
parents like I wonder what city mom and
dad are in this week kind of thing like
I uh yeah I don't I don't want to be
stuck in my house when I'm 65 every day
you know wait
for my favorite soap op to come on TV
you know I think running around and
having more fun seeing seeing more
things and meeting C people is the way
to go fantastic um any so for people
who've who've kind of listened to all of
this so far who vied with your message
we'll put links to your books and the
podcast and everything in the video
description and the show notes depending
on where people are seeing this but any
other books or resources that you would
recommend for people if they're
interested in this kind of youpreneur
thing or anything else that maybe a
Guide to Becoming a bonsai tree expert
or something like that
there any kind of any kind of book
recommendations I'm always in the market
for book recommendations I got a so
crush it by Gary I mean that was
probably the one book actually I
remember picking that up in maybe 2009 I
think uh and that book really got me
thinking about putting myself out there
more in regards to what it is that I
because we were already running our
businesses at this point in the
Outsourcing game uh and I was like well
you know if there are more people out
there and we were kind of R riding on
Tim's a little bit with the VA Focus if
there are more people out there that
want to know more about vas and virtual
assistants and building teams like that
then maybe I can help them and that's
when I started shooting YouTube videos
on my balcony at 1 p.m. and trying to
get swiped by mosquitoes and all this
sort of type of stuff um crush it
without a doubt has it dated yes
unfortunately it has but it's a kind of
book I remember reading it in one
sitting it's that kind of book you can
just blow through on a quick flight or
something so that's an absolute must
have um I also love uh going back to Zig
Ziggler see you at the top uh it's one
of those books has it aged a little yeah
it has but I would suggest don't read it
listen to it get the audio book because
there's something about zig's tones that
you just fall in love with he's great um
so I would say see what the top for sure
and uh yeah I mean there's a whole bunch
of books man but those two I think very
specifically in regards to like personal
branding and putting yourself out there
nice yeah and final question any um any
parting advice for me you know I'm 28
years old doing this personal brand
thing dude you're doing just fine what
what what should I keep in mind as I
kind of continue with this sort of stuff
I would
say maybe not so much a strategy or or
or a tip or maybe a warning if more than
anything else
right and I talk about it
in in Rise of the upo I talk about
relationships very specifically and how
you can you know you can build different
types of relation or you will build
different types of relationships
throughout the course of your business
growing your career growing etc etc but
understand and really respect the fact
that relationships should be treasured
not
used because particularly in the online
business
World um there is a lot of the using
going on I'm going to get close to this
person because I want to be on their
podcast or I want to get close to this
person because I want them to promote my
book or my course to their 100,000 email
list or whatever right I call a massive
amount of BS on those types of
individuals like I I am friends with
some of the most influential names in
the online business space I have never
ever asked them to do anything for me
and that is still the reason why when
I'm in town I get invites to go and
sleep in their house or in their
apartments or the reason why they pick
me up from the airport when I land like
these are the kind of relationships that
I truly treasure every January I sit and
write a whole bunch of cards and I send
them to people from all around the world
and this year I think I sent about 30 or
so out and these are people that maybe
I've not seen them for a while or maybe
they've had their first baby or they
they've unfortunately lost somebody
close to them whatever it is maybe it
was something I saw them do that really
resonated with me and I didn't bring it
up to them because I was just it was it
was an Instagram story or whatever but I
wanted them to know that it mattered to
me that sort of stuff is that's a
non-negotiable in January I send those
cards out and I write them with a
fountain pen it's just it's a whole
thing for me so I just genuinely look at
the relationships that come your way be
wary of people wanting to become buddies
with you because of who you are and the
platform that you built and understand
that you know true friends real re real
relationships are very very tough to
build but if you put it if you if you
put it at the very center of everything
that you do then you will build the
right kind of relationships and those
kind of relationships can be treasured
for sure fantastic Chris thank you so
much thank you all right so that's it
for this week's episode of Deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye